only et is at home with Jamie Lynn
Spears in Kentwood Louisiana for an
exclusive sit-down the 25 year old got
candid about her unconventional
upbringing you and Britney achieved fame
at very young ages and you were both
forced to live out the highs and lows of
your personal and professional lives
very publicly if you could go back we
kind of touched on this a little bit
before is there anything you would
change now about the way you grow up I
don't believe in like changing anything
because if you change one thing I'm
really big on you wouldn't be exactly
where you are right now I would say the
only thing that I maybe would change is
that I wish my whole family could all
still live in Louisiana yeah that would
be nice if like all of our houses were
like a block away from each other that
to me I think would be probably the best
thing in the whole entire world how does
the family really support each other in
the tough times I think that just like
any other family we hold each other
accountable because that's what families
are supposed to do but at the end of the
day we stand by them because we love
them and we know their heart so I think
that it's important to you know hold
hold the people you have accountable but
still be their biggest supporters for
even more from our interview with Jamie
Lynn tune in to ET on Tuesday
you